does Jordan have any friends like you
don't you want to be Jordan but you
don't want to be all Jordan the guy
don't look happy
I mean his bloodshot eyes all the time
he's [ __ ] just like he just man that
was my horse yes there's a cost of
greatness and like I was talking about
guys last night in the group chat about
this and I was just like man I see I
recognized real-time the things that I
have to sacrifice to get what I want
right like I want to wear the belt
yeah I want to be the greatest at
stand-up right and I want to hold that
position for a time and I'm and I have
this like maniacal focus for doing that
right but I also recognize the cost of
that is not seeing my family a lot not
last time me and the homies went out to
dinner I can't remember yeah they like
yeah it's like and I'm talking about
like my high school boys are my college
boys so it's like I'm in this situation
where I know what I want and I will make
these sacrifices in order to get it
but I still need to have the camaraderie
of friendship like that should is so
valuable to me so I could never work
with someone that I don't enjoy being
around mmm for me I couldn't do it
because I know the cost I know what I
have to sacrifice in order to do this so
I can't I can't just go oh yeah that
person is really cool put him there I
hate him I'm not gonna do it because
what then all is said I'm on an island
mmm
do you know me like I think I don't know
I know what Jordan stands at that maybe
Jordan could maybe join was like I don't
care but none these [ __ ] even
earlier in his career right he was like
they were all doing drugs and [ __ ] and I
was just by myself in the room his first
practice I need to find who the leader
is and take their demo figure out that's
he's a whole mentality but you don't
would you rather be Larry Bird who seems
relatively happy and is one of the goats
for the rest of your life or MJ and
you're the greatest ever but you don't
seem happy ever no I like bird bird yeah
like because bird wore the belt like my
field is like you just have the you just
have to wear you'll have to but like you
have to wear it for your generation you
know I mean you have to wear it for
point of time it's like I look at it
like boxing or like you know wrestling
or like MMA or way these things like
wearing that belt at a point you you
have to wear that belt in a time in
history you know because at the end of
the day we look at Jordan as the goat
now people will not eventually just like
Bill Russell was looked at as a goat and
they won't time moves on you forget the
greatest war general who knows who the
[ __ ] it was maybe we look at the
greatest war general as Alexander or
Napoleon or something like that
I'm sure back in the day there was some
other [ __ ] Caesar [ __ ] Larry
nerd LeBron the guy we always say who's
is he's second Jordan's first LeBron is
second LeBron and his wife are solid I
mean I'm sure he gets what he gets and
she cool with that and they got a
wonderful agreement and his kids love
the [ __ ] out of him mm-hmm he's got
friends his teammates love the [ __ ] out
of them would you rather be the
second-best and everybody loves you and
you have like a full life or I was the
greatest and I gave up literally
everything his kids don't hopefully sees
kids talking about him like that I guess
I guess like what are you gonna say mark
no oh I thought you were bringing the
mic the I guess when I guess what I'm
saying is like we look at him as a
second best but there's a generation of
people beneath us they grew up with him
yeah like we grew up with Jordan they
see him as the best so best is
subjective to time and that's why I feel
like you just got to wear it if that's
what you want if that's the goal wearing
it because once you wear it history will
dictate history documentaries
conversation pieces like Kareem
abdul-jabbar should be in the
conversation but history is not being
kind to him
Yeah right so history will dictate that
narrative yeah you know and you can
control that while you're alive and then
after you're dead is very difficult to
control that but if you wear the belt is
undeniable like it's undeniable
[Applause]